bonjour ferenc al naseem merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france alors cette loi entre en
vigueur ce matin en anglais comment
est-ce que c'est perçu par les hongrois
bonjour m'a écoutée en gris
la majorité des victoires au ban donc à
voter cette loi avec le soutien de
quelques autres députés par ailleurs il
n'y a pas de débat dans la société
hongroise il ya si vous voulez les
forces progressistes qui évidemment
dénonce 7,7
cette loi qu'ils considèrent comme une
manière contournée puisqu'à la base
c'est une loi contre la pédophilie pour
la protection de l'enfance considère que
c'est une manière détournée de
s'attaquer à la communauté lgbt
alors il faut pas être dupe évidemment
dans cette loi il y à une partie qui qui
qui est pour protéger des enfants de la
promotion de l'homosexualité comme vous
avez formulées donc ça qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'en réalité il
y à une attaque permanente du lobby lgbt
selon gouvernement hongrois vers les
enfants c'est à dire que les enfants
sont ciblés par le lobby lgbt pour
qu'ils diffusent sableux l'obligé buts
et cherche à diffuser son idéologie sa
conception du monde cherche à à formater
l'esprit des enfants sur des questions
d'ordre sexuel serre sur le
l'enseignement sexualité la vision des
rapports sexuels entre adultes etc
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
inacceptable pour la majorité de
l'électorat en réalité au delà de
l'électorat guitare sorbonne mais il ya
un noyau dur progressiste qui tient
absolument à ça et qui considère que
c'est une attaque contre la gym était
donc là c'est aussi une formulation
converser tournure sémantique très
intéressante puisque en réalité ce n'est
pas du tout une attaque contre la gvt
dans la loi n'y a aucune mention des gbt
il s'agit simplement de préciser que
l'éducation sexuelle est la prérogative
exclusive des parents c'est tout voilà
c'est à dire qu'un tiers ne doit pas
pouvoir
s'impliquer dans l'éducation des enfants
alors évidemment on peut critiquer le
fait que une loi soit l'outil choisi
pour sa part ce qu'une loi peut être
parfois il est inopérante inefficaces ou
parfois peut être trop strictes ou un
peu absurde mais c'est à l'appréciation
aussi aussi des juges
le cas échéant le fait est que on va on
verra donc comment cette loi est
appliquée pour ce qui est de tout ce qui
est à la télévision par exemple
c'est l'équivalent du csa hongrois qui
sera qui sera maître en la matière ça
veut dire que d'aider des séries
télévisées par exemple pourraient être
interdites en amont ou alors y aurait-il
des des sanctions après coup après
diffusion
ça c'est à voir c'est ce que la pratique
nous montrera interdite certainement pas
il y en a certainement pas
d'interdiction de série tout au plus il
y aura certainement un sigle a posé par
exemple interdit aux moins de 18 ans par
exemple
mais il n'y a certainement pas de
censure ou d'interdiction
voilà ça sera aux parents de rester le
sait le concept de la loi c'est les
parents qui doivent rester juge de ce
que le ce à quoi leur enfant va être
exposé c'est ça le principe de la loi
alors c'est un amendement qui vous
l'avez dit est inscrit dans une loi
contre la pédocriminalité je vais la
cité je vais le citer cet amendement la
pornographie et les contenus
représentants à la sexualité qui
promeuvent la déviation de l'identité du
genre le changement de sexe ou
l'homosexualité ne doivent pas être ne
doivent pas être accessible aux moins de
18 ans c'est un amendement qui inclut
aussi la pornographie on en a pas
beaucoup parlé
donc ça concerne tout ce champ
d'application pas seulement
l'homosexualité oui bien sûr c'est à
dire que le fait que la propre la
précision de la promotion de fin le fait
qu'il y ait la précision de la promotion
de l'homosexualité c'est parce que c'est
quelque chose qui existe et qui est de
plus en plus fort et le plus en plus
marquée pareil pour les histoires de
trans identité etc
en réalité tout ça est englobé comme
comme je le disais dans la question de
la sexualité sert de londres de
l'éducation sexuelle des enfants
l'éducation sexuelle des enfants la
prérogative des parents maintenant
là il ya tout un paquet de choses
auxquelles les enfants peuvent être
exposés la pornographie ou justement la
théorie du genre les histoires de
changement de sexe et cm1 donc pour
protéger les enfants de ça en amont le
gouvernement hongrois a choisi la
stratégie de cette de cet amendement à
la loi sur la protection de l'enfance
cela dit il n'ya pas vraiment de concret
pour la pornographie par lyon c'est
toujours avec une question très
difficile
comment protéger les enfants qui
aujourd'hui ont tous des portables un
accès internet
je pense pas que cette loi soit
suffisante en soi faudrait des solutions
plus concrètes comme peut-être le ce que
proposait beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs le
notamment d'aider des gens du porno
c'est à dire des accès limité aux gens
qui ont une carte bleue par exemple
après il peut y avoir des déviations
évidemment cet amendement et est inclus
dans une loi contre la pédocriminalité
est-ce que c'est pas là finalement la
maladresse de l'avoir inclus dans dans
cette loi contre la pédocriminalité
maladresse peut-être misterp rachel oui
d'accord mais est bien à ce moment-là on
reproche une maladresse pas un
manquement l'état de droit voilà il n'y
a pas de manquement l'état de droit il
n'y a rien dans cette dans cet
amendement qui contrevient aux droits de
l'homme ou à quelques quelconque valeur
européenne ce serait bien de définir
clairement ce que sait quelles valeurs
européennes
pour certains on dirait que les valeurs
lgbt sont les valeurs européennes et
vice versa je crois qu'il faut s'en
tenir au droit et en matière de droit
l'amendement hongrois ne ne contrevient
à aucune règle donc devrait pas y avoir
de problème en tout cas au niveau de
l'état de droit c'est une question
purement politique et de vision du monde
ses détracteurs craignent d'en fermer
justement les jeunes qui sont issus de
ces 2 2 qu'ils sont homosexuels de les
enfermer dans le silence de les
marginaliser est ce que c'est une
crainte qui est soulevé également dans
votre pays n'ont écouté le dialogue a
toujours été possible
en hongrie il n'y a pas de problème ou
de tabous sur l'homosexualité il n'y a
pas de violences qui concernent les
homosexuels ou même les trans ou qui que
ce soit la hongrie est un pays très
paisible très policé qui en plus en
réalité et à tendance conservatrice mais
est quand même en parallèle assez assez
coulante s'écoulant sur le sur les
moeurs
donc il faut il faut vraiment arrêter
comme les fantasmes ce que véhicule le
monde qui est la propagande de guerre je
pèse mes mots c'est hallucinant lorsque
un journal sérieux comme le monde nos
confrères disent que des homosexuels ne
se sentent pas en sécurité en gris mais
c'est absurde c'est hallucinant il faut
venir en hongrie pour pour se rend
compte que c'est quelque chose
d'absolument absurde
sexuelles sont beaucoup plus en sécurité
à budapest qu'à paris par exemple
merci beaucoup fait wrenshall massive de
nous avoir livré votre point de vue ce
matin